[Music]
1984 has been a tough year our sales are
down our growth is down sunny I brush
you in here to grow the basketball
business
people don't know what the hell a Nike
is what's a Converse NBA All-Star shoes
there's nothing cool about Nike
you would have to have a pretty
compelling pitch I can tell them the one
thing the other companies can't compete
with
our basketball Division is terrible I do
not love it
this is where you come up with a
brilliant idea that no one else can see
let's hear it
I found him who's that Jesus can't
afford it I'm willing to bet my career
on one guy
my name is Sonny Vaccaro I'm with Nike
do you typically make it a habit of
showing up the people's front doors
unannounced I don't like to take no for
an answer oh man here we go you asked me
what I do here this is what I do I find
you players and I feel it this time yeah
okay it's risky when you were selling
sneakers out of the back of your
Plymouth that was risky don't change
that now for a rookie yes who's never
set foot on an NBA court if that's the
literal definition of rookie yeah
what's the plan we build a shoe line
around just him
I need the greatest basketball shoe
that's ever been made who's the player
Michael Jordan
[Music]
have our attention
I believe he's the future and his story
is gonna make us want to fly but a shoe
is just a shoe until my son steps into
it
[Music]
got a name for it
Air Jordan
seriously maybe it'll grow on me
[Music]